I can tell you I've jumped out of
airplanes before I've done almost every
sport there is out there and done all
these thrills I have never felt the same
as I do when I'm dancing I am a
breakdancer and I go by big girl snap
one snap because I'm actually
double-jointed and then the one was
added because I'm the only key grow up
in a Alaska i strictly compete against
boys it makes you be good not for a girl
but as a dancer
professionally on the uh-60 black ops
mechanic I spend 40 hours a week
fixing helicopters inspecting
helicopters replacing major components
being in the Army has taught me a lot of
self-discipline and focus because if my
body goes kaput I can't do my passion
hip-hop scene in Anchorage is very small
we are so far away from the rest of the
hip-hop scene in the United States and
in the world being able to accomplish
what our crew members have been able to
accomplish that's a good influence for
everybody else that lives here that if
they just put enough time and effort and
passion into their craft they can
actually go somewhere and do something
with it doing all these incredible
things if my body to the music and
battling these other people is a
remarkable feeling that I just simply
can't get anywhere else